what's happened to males in education
then
what's happened is that males have
fallen rapidly behind females at every
stage of the education system and in
every Advanced economy in the world so
if you just take the all the oecd
countries such a pretty good proxy for a
decently economically Advanced there are
more young women with a college degree
than young men in both the UK and the US
it's of 60 40 now college campuses and
that's happened incredibly quickly and
when I was born in 1969 it was about
college campuses were about 70 male 30
female by the time I went to college in
the late 80s it was about 50 50 and now
it's flipped to 60 40 the other way and
so on pretty much every measure you can
look at
um girls are ahead of boys and that's
increasingly true even established like
math and science so one of the ideas
people have in their head is like oh we
always knew girls are better at English
and women better at English and those
sorts of subjects but aren't boys much
better at math and science
but the answer is not really anymore
um you know in most places now the the
girls and women have caught up on the in
the in math and science as well and in
some cases overtaken and still have this
huge lead in literacy in English and
literacy in English turn out to be more
important for what happens to you after
that so there's been this huge
overtaking which by the way no one
predicted it's really interesting go
back and you read the stuff in the 70s
when we were really pushing for gender
equality in education to get more women
into college and especially into more
male dominated subjects and everybody
was pushing towards parity nobody
predicted that the lines would keep
going nobody predicted that once girls
and women caught up with boys and men
that they would keep going and that we
would now have a big agenda Gap in
higher education than we did 50 years
ago just the other way around so we've
flipped the inequality now and it's
actually wider now than it was when I
was born almost and certainly us it's
wide or anything in the UK it's getting
close so that's an extraordinary fact
that no one predicted and can only be
the result of structural factors if it's
happening everywhere
and every level is not the kid right
it's not Chris's problem in secondary
school in a particular education system
you know or my son's problem in the US
K-12 it's it's as a structural problem
with the education system that's just
not male friendly enough
structurally what's changed then because
just that more women are going to
college and more women are performing
better doesn't mean that men should be
doing worse
no and it's important to distinguish of
course as you imply there between
relative and absolute right so if if one
group is doing better than another then
by definition
that the other group's doing relatively
less well so agenda pay Gap right so uh
the fact that women are earning a huge
ton more than they were 50 years ago but
that doesn't mean they're caught up with
men yet so uh absolutely wages have gone
up um but in some in some cases as the
absolute educational performance of boys
has flattened or has dropped and so if
you look at white working-class boys in
the UK for example or black boys in the
US actually in some in many areas
they're actually sliding backwards and
but you're right to kind of point to the
distinction between relative and
absolute what I think has happened
is that the education system is just
structured in favor of women and girls
because it it rewards certain kinds of
behaviors at critical ages in particular
turning your homework in being planned
for being organized being committed
sticking on the task being future
oriented about the age of 16.
which is when the gender gap in those
skills is at its widest and so what
happens is the girl's brains just
develop earlier than boys it's just a
biological fact and in particular in the
in the prefrontal cortex this bit of the
brain that's the CEO of the brain it is
the bit that turns your homework in that
that says it's the bit of your brain
that stops you going to the party and
makes you stay in studying chemistry
right
it's the bit of the brain that every
parent waits to develop in their sons
basically parenting is like a a 10-year
process of being the substitute
prefrontal cortex for your boy have you
got kids have you got Sons no not yet
all right well trust me that's what it
is you're basically just going to be
their prefrontal cortex until when is it
coming when is it coming and the answer
is much later than in girls and so it's
no surprise that girls are doing better
the surprises that they weren't doing
better before why weren't they doing
better before because of sexism
the truth is that girls were always at a
structural advantage in education but we
couldn't see it because it was never
expressed in things like college going
exam taking and so on because they were
preparing for a life of being a wife and
mother
as soon as we took the prayer time in
the structural advantage that women had
was exposed so in a sense by leveling
apparently leveling the playing field in
education
what we revealed was that the women are
much better players
and they are as a result largely in my
view of development it's also true that
we don't have enough male teachers that
the pedagogy is not male friendly and so
on too there's a whole bunch of things
going on but taken as a whole you look
at the school system it's impossible to
come to any conclusion other than that
this suits girls better than adults boys
that's fascinating the fact that this
has always been lurking below the
surface this has always been the way
that the population within schools has
been performing but because of lack of
access lack of encouragement
gendered discrimination that has
restricted women from being females from
being able to reach their full potential
in the education system it's only when
you've been able to open up those doors
that the underlying
um disparity has been able to fully show
itself and I suppose that
it's difficult because if that was the
case previously
the Assumption now is that the only
reason there could be a disparity
between boys and girls performance is
now due to some other type of
restriction or sexism it's by boys being
told something restricted in some way so
using the previous model of what was the
solution to the problem for women and
now mapping that onto
the issue that manifesting or boys
so it seems like it's more deep rooted
than that this isn't the sort of thing
yes that is that is occurring in the
culture this is something which is
occurring in biology from a very early
age
yeah it's it's happening in the system
itself that's a that's a great
distinction so I think that the main
problem that the uh women and girls
faced before was they just had breaks on
there just had barriers it was like
didn't go to coming like my my dad went
to college because you know that was why
he was gonna hopefully earn more money
and be able to raise family my my mum
was basically encouraged to leave high
school at 17 and said do you want to be
a nurse
um and the idea that should have gone I
just would just didn't happen
um you know and so you don't have to go
and it's so quick this change
um that's taken place but you're exactly
right and it's hard I think for people
to get their head around that because
it's happened so quickly that the idea
that people it's tough to get people to
to get their head around the idea that
boys could be a structural disadvantage
in the education system which until
incredibly recently seemed to be serving
poison men much better than girls and
women like literally in the blink of an
eye
and then there's a mistake that's made
along exactly the lines that you've just
identified which is that some people say
oh there must be discrimination against
boys in education and you get books like
the war against boys the war on men Etc
which is that there is intentional
discrimination against boys and there's
almost no evidence
no evidence of that like no one is
saying to but no one said to my boys
when they're going through high school
or don't you worry about college just
find yourself a nice wife and settle
down no one was saying that they were
saying for God's sake turn your homework
in so that you stand a chance of going
to college you idiot so it isn't
discrimination but it it is instead the
mixture of the Chrono the difference
between the chronological age and
developmental age of the average boy and
girl especially in adolescence has been
revealed by by the women's movement and
also progressively teaching as a
profession has become more and more
female over time and so we're a fewer
and fewer male teachers in schools and
that does seem to affect my health
performance or reasons that are complex
and so on too and there's been a bit of
a shift away from styles of learning
that seem a bit more boy friendly and
male friendly like vocational education
for example which does seem to suit on
average overlapping distributions
seem to suit males uh more than females
and so for all so there's been a series
of Trends in education that have that
have I think exacerbated this underlying
structural problem which is a 16 year
old girl is older than a 16 year old boy
in terms of her developmental uh
abilities
just how
big is the
did I hear you say that it was two
percent of kindergarten teachers in
America are male some insanely small
proportion
yeah it's it's about it's about two
percent yeah
um and it's not going up either uh it's
similar in the UK
um these numbers actually do map pretty
well across U.S and you get a one in ten
um uh Elementary School teachers or
Primary School teachers male and in in
uh one of my one of my sons actually
works in early years education so I get
this you know a lot of this you know
through him and he's one of the very few
males of course working in that space uh
and so when you dig into numbers here
it's about two percent which is
very low number and to put it in
perspective as a share of the profession
there are twice as many or even three
times as many women flying U.S military
planes
as there are men teaching kindergarten
and Pre-K classes so we have about three
times as so three times it's about seven
percent seven percent of U.S military
Pilots now women now I'm happy to have a
conversation about whether that's too
low you know what should that number be
and of what's actually happening of
course is that the most the air forces
are doing this yourself they're
redesigning the cockpits of planes
so that they're not designed anymore
around a presumed kind of male uh height
which will allow shorter men to be
Pilots do
um but it's also most important so
they're actively recruiting they're
changing the design of fighter planes to
get more women great
what's happening to get more men into
Early Education
answer
nothing
and so there is isn't even seen as a
problem to be addressed let alone one
that we're propering solutions for and
so it's one of the reasons I'm really
emphasizing this point what's happening
people if you enjoyed that then press
here for a selection of the best clips
from the podcast over the last few weeks
and don't forget to subscribe
peace
[Music]